to wander this mausoleum and shiraz iran  is like stepping into the holiest of  light show  [Music]  the shot channel which roughly  translates to king of the light and  persian is a funerary monument and  mosque a beautiful holy place for  thousands of Muslim worshippers the  structure is made of multicolored pieces  of tile and glass and is considered to  be the third most important pilgrimage  sites in Iran initially started around  900 AD as a burial site for an important  Shia Muslim figure the mosque continued  to be expanded and improved the decision  to adorn the mosque with its iconic  Mirrorball decoration came from Queen  toshka tune in the 14th century she  wanted the mosque to intensify any light  a thousand times over in homage to the  mosque's name although meant to be a  holy shrine an important pilgrimage  location for Shia Muslims people of any  faiths can marvel at the mosque immense  beauty  you  [Music]